the media is always looking for
something to blame in part it's
motivated by a political desire to find
a group that isn't politically active or
politically powerful as a scapegoat the
Department of Justice is at the Hat
Phillips house taking on their
ammunition and their guns so they have
my guns outside taking pictures of it
where the neighbors are driving by
in the wake of mass shootings our media
and our politicians tend to focus on two
things banning certain kinds of weapons
and keeping weapons out of the hands of
certain kinds of people none of us want
crazy people having guns look what
happened I'm afraid that that
semi-automatic weapon is going to fall
into the hands of a crazy person dozen
more killers a hundred more how can we
possibly even guess how many given our
nation's refusal to create an active
national database of the mentally ill
that's Wayne LaPierre head spokesperson
for the National Rifle Association an
active national database of the middlee
Gil even the nation's premier gun lobby
believes the database to keep guns away
from the mentally ill seems like a good
idea better safe than sorry it seems
well logical but what if there's a
serious flaw in that logic there is no
evidence that the mentally ill account
for a largely disproportionate amount of
violence or gun violence here's the
entire population of people with a
mental illness diagnosis and when you
control for the complicating factor of
substance abuse here is the number of
them statistically likely to commit a
violent act only about 4% general
strategies that forensic psychiatrists
take is that one never attempts to
predict violence in a large pool of
unselected individuals if you have a
test that is 90% accurate and you
applied it to a hundred thousand people
the rate of violence is is roughly half
a percent in the general population so
there are 500 real violent people
but you've identified 10,000 people
inappropriately as being violent in the
absence of a history of violence or any
of the other risk factors it is
impossible to identify who will go on to
become violent for every individual who
goes on a shooting rampage there are a
hundred or perhaps more individuals who
also had
disturbed relationships with teachers
parents authorities want to know what
caused the alleged gunman Jared Lee lost
nur to snap we hear it over and over
again if you've been transported to a
psych ward the shootings might never
happen there were clear warning signs
here to talk about the warning signs
indication we have been picking up some
signs we should be looking for
individuals once we know the outcome it
is easy to look back and perceive a
pattern that seems to be leading to a
common event often that's simply
hindsight bias if we put doctors in a
position of acting on behalf of the
government or acting on behalf of social
control then that undermines the
therapeutic mission restricting the
rights to people who are living with a
mental illness or possibly may be
diagnosed with the mental illness
just further perpetuates people not
receiving or seeking the treatment that
they need to get better and we know
prevention early intervention and
seeking that treatment right on the
onset is what supports people in
recovery so most people with mental
illnesses never do anything violent and
it's almost impossible to predict who's
going to snap without a prior history of
violence but still what's the harm in
taking precautions to answer that
question we turn to California
California's armed prohibited person
system aims to confiscate guns from
three groups those with a history of
violence wanted criminals and anyone the
state believes has a severe mental
illness because one nurse wrote false
information now I'm on a prohibited
persons list I've never done anything to
hurt anybody
Lynette Phillips and her husband David
have never committed a violent crime and
Lynette certainly not a wanted felon but
she does have a mental illness I was
diagnosed about thirteen years ago with
anxiety disorder once I was diagnosed I
felt okay this makes sense now all this
excessive worrying and once the
medication started taking effect I fell
like a normal person Lynette ran into
trouble when she switched her medication
from a pill to a patch she rushed the
transition because she wanted to be well
in time for her first Christmas with a
new granddaughter what in the papen was
I couldn't stop crying there wasn't
anything I saw experienced everything
would make me cry desperate to stop
crying
Lynette asked her son to find a hospital
for her to check herself into so she
could stabilize her mood the local
hospital was full so they ended up at a
facility called Aurora Charter Oak
that's where my nightmare started I
thought my nightmare crying wasn't it
that was a piece of cake - I was
admitted based on me being suicidal that
I could potentially drive my car off a
cliff which I never said those words the
nurse never said those words so where
the cliff came into play
I don't know once I said goodbye to my
husband once I got to the unit they did
their assessment and started giving me
paperwork and that's when I realized I
was being I was 5150 involuntarily being
admitted
despite voluntarily seeking treatment
Lynette was involuntarily committed to
the hospital representatives at Aurora
Charter Oak declined to comment for this
story but Lynette says she was released
before the full 72 hours once the
hospital psychiatrist actually had a
chance to see her he said better
policies and procedures should be in
effect so this doesn't happen
nobody apologized that's closest to an
apology is I got Lynette has a letter
from her personal psychiatrist backing
up her claim that she sought treatment
voluntarily but because of the
involuntary commitment she suddenly
became an arms prohibited person
California Department of Justice officer
with no warrant and took every gun in
the house
I don't even didn't even know what gun
was I bought for Dave for Christmas
couldn't have told you I've never loaded
a gun
you bring nine officers to the house you
surround the house how much is that
costing they didn't need to do that they
embarrassed us in the in the
neighborhood it is humiliating when
somebody comes to your door and treats
you like a criminal
it's not how we should be treating
people who are living with an illness to
the extent that society continues to
vilify the mentally ill and escape goat
them as being the primary cause of gun
violence is is a major step backward
there needs to be some better policing
of who who they're coming after
[Music]
you